a local prosecutor and a judge in
Michigan are under fire for giving a
convicted rapist joint legal custody of
his victim's eight-year-old son
Christopher Mia solo pleaded guilty in
2008 to attempted third degree criminal
sexual assault last month
Santa Lac district judge that's Gregory
Ross signed an order allowing me our
solo joint custody rights of his victims
child it came after she applied for
state aid the judge put the order on
hole yesterday after learning of mere
solos background a hearing is scheduled
for this month
Tony Jacopo's spoke to the victim and
her attorney in Rochester Michigan about
their effort to protect other rape
victims from facing painful legal
circumstances I don't understand why
they thought that they needed to give
him joint legal custody he was my rapist
Tiffany was 12 in 2008 when she says
Christopher mera Solo forced himself on
her in an abandoned house near Detroit
now 21 she's raising her eight-year-old
son on her own she agreed to go on
camera but asked that we use only her
first name I was kidnapped for two days
I didn't know if I was ever gonna go
home he threatened to kill me and my
best friend if we if we told anyone
mera Solo was given a plea deal for
attempted third degree criminal sexual
conduct and served six and a half months
in county jail he served jail time again
after being convicted of raping another
victim between the ages of 13 and 15
years old in 2010 but last month Sante
Lac County prosecuting attorney James V
young and Santa Lac District Court Judge
Gregory Ross signed a paternity order
that gives Tiffany's attacker joint
legal custody of their son and the right
to pursue parenting time I was receiving
government assistance and they told me
if I did not tell them who the father
was my child that they would take that
away from me what kind of things come up
when you hear his name and see his face
horrible things horrible images
flashbacks the Santa Lac County
Prosecutor's Office said it prepared a
standard order that is used in all
paternity cases and that Tiffany was
required to cooperate as a condition of
receiving
financial assistance what did you think
about their request that it was crazy
why because I have been taking care of
her for eight years I gave up high
school I gave up prom I gave up my
friends to raise a baby and go to work
Tiffani's attorney Rebecca Kiessling
says this case reveals a troubling
nationwide gap in the way states deal
with rape victims who request aid
there's no policy I've had rape victims
who were cut off from state aid because
they couldn't name the rapist because
they were abducted by a stranger or
because a sex trafficker kidnapped them
and raped them attorneys for Tiffany and
Mira solo say they are now working
privately to reach a settlement for CBS
this morning tonita Kopu Sandusky
Michigan the sandlot County Prosecutor's
Office says it plans to conduct an
internal review of how cases like
Tiffany's are handled and make any
appropriate changes on that there seem
like all kind of wrong levels on that
story but really brave of her to speak
up the way she is kind of live by